[Music]
morning everybody it is
seven o'clock here in the uk good to
have you company wherever you're
watching us in the world today all
eyes are on the 21st of june here and
whether the prime minister will decide
to delay
freedom day but it's a precarious
situation with the delta variant on the
rise
after the environment secretary told us
we should holiday at home this year
we'll be speaking to the housing
secretary robert generic today about
lockdown vaccines holidays weddings
and sausage gate he joins us in just a
moment
also for you this morning i'm going to
be looking more
at this fuming travel industry leaders
are demanding the traffic light system
must be scrapped we'll speak to ryan air
boss michael o'leary
and take you to a quarantine hotel where
a redless traveler is settling in
for a 10-day stay and
if we don't do this
there will be nothing left to say
get your popcorn ready the summer's
biggest blockbusters are here the
founder of view cinemas takes us through
the best of the bunch
at a quarter to nine it's wednesday the
9th of june
as decision time looms on the ending of
lockdown do rising covey cases in the
northwest
signal a delay
you shall go to the ball andrew lloyd
webber says his cinderella show
will go ahead on the 21st of june come
what may
and he's prepared to be arrested for it
sausage wars showdown talks with the eu
as the government battles to avoid a
trade war with brussels
helpers my sisters need strength the
family of twins attacked by a crocodile
in mexico
make crowdfunding appeal to help pay for
their medical fees
revealed the text messages about an
alleged mega drug drop
off a cargo ship following an
international crime sting
good morning for many of us it's going
to be another warm sunny and
fine day and temperatures will continue
to rise could be quite hot
by the weekend
[Music]
and so the clock is ticking down to the
moment the government must decide
whether to go ahead
with so-called freedom day on the 21st
of june reports this morning
suggest the chancellor rishi sunak of
course has come round the idea of a
four-week delay to the lock down lifting
the treasury tells us its position
remains that we need to see what the
data says
the government is also under pressure
from the travel industry with industry
leaders
calling for the traffic light system to
be scrapped altogether
that comes as the delta variant is
changing the domestic picture
millions of people in the northwest are
now under a new package of support
including
increased testing and guidance on
limiting travel
isabel rasheed reports from manchester
12 days to go until we lift fully out of
lockdown
but today the north west is waking up
with additional coved guidance
the indian variant continues to cause
concern
and force the government to send up an
emergency response package
to help i want to encourage everyone in
manchester and lancashire to get the
tests
on offer we know that this approach
can work we've seen it work in south
london
and in bolton in stopping
a rise in the number of cases
the announcement of extra vaccines more
testing
and military support is welcome but the
package comes with
caution minimize travel and only meet
people outside where possible
these aren't local lockdown restrictions
but it feels like it for many
i think we've got to stop hitting one
part of the country against the other
um and i think you know where we have
spikes
we have to do more of this and not put
people into localized lot dancing it
feels like it's always the same areas
why i don't understand that um again
i'm not conspiracist or anything but why
why is it always the same areas
for some conservative backbenchers who
are critical of delaying lifting
restrictions
the new guidance is up for
interpretation
now i've read the guidance it's advice
blanket advice to everybody
do you think that actually people should
make their own decisions based on
whether they have had zero
one or two vaccinations something that
the government actually is silent on
well i do because clearly if you're in
one of the groups for example that's at
risk
of becoming seriously or from code word
but you and you haven't been vaccinated
firstly my advice would be
go and get vaccinated but secondly
if you haven't been vaccinated you
should clearly be more careful
if you've been vaccinated and have both
of your vaccinations
you're clearly more protected and i
think people need to make
take those things into account as they
make judgments about how they live their
lives
this region has been here before it's
vulnerable to restrictions once again
and over four million people find
themselves staring down the barrel of a
step backwards
a big question mark remains over whether
we move forward together
as a nation or if this already bruised
region
is once again left behind in saman
rashid sky news
manchester the housing secretary robert
generic is with us i want to talk about
manchester in just a second if we may mr
janet good morning but first
freedom day that's what everybody is
talking about
looking at this morning's papers
complete confusion
uh mr gove saying if he was a betting
man the restrictions would be relaxed
was she soon as
saying potentially that he'd accept a
four-week delay the backbencher powerful
backbencher steve baker saying
don't you dare what's your view well i'm
not going to comment on the discussions
that are happening within the cabinet
but
the prime minister is reviewing the data
and more data is coming in
which is very important we created this
five week period between the stages of
the robot and that has actually proved
invaluable
on this occasion because it's a finely
balanced decision
and we need to see that data of cases
which are clearly rising
but the link to hospitalizations and
ultimately to death so
the pm is reviewing that ahead of the
decision point which is going to be the
14th
of june at that point of course he'll
let everybody know what the ultimate
decision is but you're a secretary of
state you have a view what's your view
well i'm not going to give my view the
obviously those views
are made privately within the cabinet
but what i do think is important
is that we don't throw away the gains
that we've made so
we're going to take a cautious approach
but if we can proceed with that
reopening on the 21st
of course all of us would love to see
that for in our own lives and the
livelihoods that depend on that further
reopening
yeah something you will have a view on
andrew lloyd webber on the front page of
the telegraph today i'm sure you've seen
it he's
launching his multi-million pound
production of cinderella on the west end
stage
he says that is going to happen come
hell or high water no matter what you
decide about the 21st of june
and if you want the police can come and
arrest us if the restrictions aren't
lifted
should the police arrest him well i
completely empathize with andrew lloyd
webber and
more importantly all of the people who
work in the cultural sector people who
work in theaters and
and other venues for whom it's been a
very difficult year amongst other
parts of the economy we want to get them
open
we are doing pilots we want to get those
theaters open so great new productions
uh like cinderella can open i know that
people are desperate to go to them
tickets
are selling fast for all those
productions because people have been
away too long
but you just got a few more days to wait
until the judgment that the prime
minister is going to make
on the base of the data and in answer to
my question should he be arrested if he
breaks those rules
well look i i'm sure that andrew lloyd
webber's comments are made um
in the heat of the moment what what he's
very serious well he i'm sure he feels
this very strongly but look we all have
to
do our best to abide by he'll be
arrested he says come and arrest us
well we all have to abide by the rules
yes isn't it um i'm not going to get
into uh speculation about that but we
want to get those theaters back open
obviously
as quickly as we can to support people
like andrew lloyd webber so that we can
all enjoy brilliant productions in the
west end once again what about those 50
000 weddings that are
at risk if we are postponed for another
month what would you say to uh
prospective
bride and grooms at the moment well
weddings can go ahead
right now but with a maximum of 30. 30
guests and
people ranging sorry now i appreciate
that that that's very tough and i would
like to
to see the number of people attending
weddings increase
we're giving that careful thought that
will be one of the topics that uh the pm
will address
on the 14th of june so again people are
looking forward to those but don't have
very long to wait for them so
what's your advice to those people who
are you know hovering up with the red
marker pen over who
can no longer be invited potentially
well we've always said that the road map
um is subject to review of the data that
is what is happening right now so
whether it's weddings or international
travel or any of these other important
topics
you always have to wait until the
judgment is made on the basis of the
data
at the decision point so i i wouldn't
make plans
until you've heard from the pm if that's
important to you but weddings can go
ahead
right now but just with the maximum of
30 guests what can go ahead in
manchester
and lancashire right now greater
manchester i should say
meet outdoors and minimize travel is
what people are being told what does
minimizing travel actually mean
what's that look like well these are
guidelines so we're offering some extra
advice to
people who live in that area this isn't
the law
but you can clearly see that cases are
rising in manchester
and so we're asking people to use their
personal judgment
personal responsibility in order to help
us
to bring down the number of cases and
we've done that in bolton
very successfully a huge effort by
people there
great work by the local council and the
nhs
so we want to replicate that model in
greater manchester clearly
although bolton is the biggest town in
england greater manchester is a much
larger
connection and so it's going to be a big
job but we're going to give all the
support we possibly can
through the nhs to surge testing through
armed
forces support as well to try to do that
and people can play their part
by limiting their contact with other
people taking
that guidance seriously and above all by
going out and getting vaccinated
having your second jab if you haven't
already if you're a younger person now
who's eligible going and get vaccinated
because we're really in a race
between the vaccine rollout and the
virus and in those places in particular
where cases are rising
you need to go and get vaccinated as
quickly as you can i hope you're not
saying i'm old because i've had both
vaccines
not at all okay please check it but it
is great news okay
we've got this huge surge in young
people going to get vaccinated
so we've seen half a million young
people registering booking their
appointments
just within a matter of days since matt
hancock the health secretary announced
that
uh younger age groups are now eligible
and lots of those young people want to
go
on holiday abroad i am confused what the
what the guidance is from the government
on foreign holidays what is it
well let me be clear you shouldn't be
booking holidays
to countries that are currently on
either the amber list
or the red list you can go to the
admittedly relatively small number of
countries on
the green list even there be aware that
this isn't a normal summer
for holidays we are reviewing that list
every three weeks and so
i would advise people to look for travel
operators who can offer flexibility
will be able to offer rescheduling or
repayments if something changes
we would like to open up that green list
to more countries
but we've obviously got to do so
cautiously so we're reviewing
cases and hospitalizations in those
countries and also
looking at whether those countries have
the level of genomic sequencing that's
required to give us comfort
that there are new variants that might
be of concern to us
and if we can open up more we obviously
will do because we'd love to give people
more opportunities to travel george
eustis yesterday sat there
front page of the times now as a result
saying we should holiday at home this
year
well i think a lot of people are coming
to the conclusion
perfectly understandably that this isn't
a normal summer opportunities for
international travel are going to be
more limited
and so why not enjoy everything that
this country has to offer
uh this summer that's probably the
decision that i'm going to make many
other people will be doing the same but
we would like to offer people the
opportunity to go to more of those green
list countries
but that's very dependent on what's
happening there and
we can't control the vaccination rollout
in those countries
we obviously can't control the spread of
new variants and we have to do
everything that we can
to protect all that we're achieving here
domestically
so on balance the correct decision is to
holiday at home this year and that's
what you're going to do
no i'm not saying that i'm saying that
it's a matter for individuals
we've set up a framework which i hope is
clear which is that you should really
only be booking well you should only be
booking
holidays to countries that are currently
on the green list and even there
you should be aware that they're subject
to review every three weeks
so you have to try to um either exercise
caution when you do that or
try to get uh holidays that you can get
rescheduled or refunded should something
change so for many people they may
conclude that the safest option
is to enjoy what this country has to
offer this summer and that's the right
thing to do
well it's not a question of what's right
or wrong i'm trying to give the best
possible advice to people
people will make their own judgments you
can choose to book a holiday
to a country that's on the green list
but there's always a degree of risk
involved in that because those countries
are reviewed as we've seen
with portugal and things can move quite
quickly um is the prime minister
holidaying abroad this year
i don't know i haven't asked him but i
know that he's going to cornwall
i know that he's going to well he's got
a lot of other things on his mind i know
that he's going to cornwall today
to carver's bait which is a place that
he knows well and loves
ready to welcome the leaders of the g7
to the united kingdom which brings us on
to
brexit and sausage wars as it's being
described um
lord frost is the brexit secretary he's
meeting his counterpart today and the pm
uh is meeting uh president biden
tomorrow i think
um a uk u.s trade deal we're led to
believe relies on the outcome of this
sausage wars um what an absolute mess
this is
well look we want to see a sensible
pragmatic
outcome to this when we signed up to the
protocol it was always envisaged that
there would be
hard edges that needed to be shaved off
and ironed out
in the weeks ahead and in fact the
protocol committed both sides to using
best endeavors
to sort out these sorts of things and
that's exactly what we want we we've put
forward some solutions
to the eu we hope that they will come to
the table today
as you say maracovich the eu's uh
interlocutor is meeting with lord frost
and we want to try to sort this out
because it can't be right
that a supermarket in northern ireland
can't have access to the same goods as
one
in wales scotland or england and a
sausage can't travel from
bangor in wales to bangor in northern
ireland we must be able to sort that out
um indulge me and listen to what michael
gove had to say about
it we need to make sure that the
uh the sausages that our supermarket
chains provide to
citizens in northern ireland can
continue to flow
we've secured that agreement with the
commission and that means that some of
the disruption
which people feared might occur after
the end of the transition period
won't occur well michael gove was
absolutely right i don't think
either side when we signed up to the
protocol envisaged that the eu would
interpret it in such a rigid and
unpragmatic way and we're asking them to
show some
common sense and enable something as
simple as
some chilled meats like a sausage to
travel from
gb to northern ireland because the
protocol was always
about ensuring the free flow of goods
between gb and northern ireland
as it was between northern ireland and
the european union
and i hope that we can sort those out
because there are also things even more
important
than sausages at stake here for example
medicines
it really would be absurd if a cancer
drug
struggled to be um dispatched
from the mainland of the united kingdom
to northern ireland
and we need to sort this out now so it's
the eu's fault for sticking to the
letter of the agreement
well the protocol itself envisaged that
there would be
sensible pragmatic discussions entered
into
in good faith and that it would evolve
with time and to some extent that's
happened we've actually made
a lot of progress on a number of fronts
but on this front
there now needs to be a resolution and i
hope these discussions today will
take that forwards um although you were
told by three former prime ministers
um and indeed the cbi that it would be
much more complicated and
um we were told by the prime minister it
was an overready deal
we have until the end of june to sort
this out um if the uk
unilaterally extends that grace period
which we have done on
other aspects of this agreement then
we're hearing from the eu this morning
that they will retaliate strongly with
legal action
in their words how seriously should the
british government take that threat
well that we want to work in good faith
with our european friends
and neighbours we don't want to get into
legal action
and it would be absurd if there were
legal cases over whether
a sausage manufactured in birmingham
could
be exported to be sold in sainsbury's
in belfast that that doesn't make sense
that is not a good use of
the time of either country so i hope
that common sense will prevail
and the discussions that are going to
happen late today the first meeting of
this new council
will be the opportunity to break the
deadlock or at least
to move in the right direction yeah
fantastic alliteration but the eu will
say yeah
whatever we are going to threaten you
with legal action meantime the other
side of the pond they're saying
unless you sort out this deal there is
no us uk trade deal
well i think if you in respect of the uk
and the united states
our interests are aligned here both
countries have an
unshakable commitment to the good friday
agreement
and that's what we want to preserve and
support here
the good friday agreement was clear that
northern ireland
is part of the united kingdom for as
long as its residents
want to be so and that trade should flow
freely between
uh the two nations and that's what we
want to see preserved and so i think
uh president biden and boris johnson
will be entirely aligned
in their position we want a sensible
outcome to this
which preserves the position of northern
ireland within the united kingdom
and if you think about it it would be
ridiculous
for a u.s president to even consider
that something grown in alabama
couldn't be uh moved across the state
border to a neighboring state or a
medicine
produced in california couldn't be flown
to
be jabbed into the arm of somebody in
new york so i think
the president and others will see the
good sense of the british position
and hopefully all the parties will come
to a resolution as quickly as we can
whose fault is it that there's a border
in the irish sea
well we have signed up to a protocol
which enabled northern ireland quite
rightly
to remain within the same customs
territory of the united kingdom
and that's the simple principle that
we're trying to enforce in okay
we're out of time everybody's rushing me
but i just wanted to ask you very
quickly about time swans tell me about
it
yeah well we just wanted to say a big
thank you to the people of cornwall
for hosting the g7 it's going to be a
fantastic
event the first meeting of the leaders
of the big western open societies
for almost two years and cornwall and
cornish people cornish police
have got huge efforts to stage this
event which i think will be a brilliant
one
and so today the prime minister is
announcing a series
of town deals to support communities
like saint ives like penzance
like truro so that they can have
transformative investments in local
infrastructure in culture
in green infrastructure cycle lanes and
and pathways along the coast really
important things which will help to
build back better that beautiful part of
the country you're upbeat this morning
aren't you holidaying at home this year
are you i think so yeah i might i might
even go to cornwall oh there we go it's
lovely to see you thank you for joining
us
thank you thank you still to come on the
program for you this morning
dr david navarro covert 19 envoy to the
world health organisation joins us
at a quarter to eight our rising cases
in the north west a sign of potential
road map delays we speak
to greater manchester mayor andy burnham
at 20 past
eight at quarter to ten
i'll be speaking to bafta winning
documentary producer stephen mcginty
about the untold story of the world's
deepest submarine rescue
now she said it is a social media post
she never thought she'd have to make the
older sister of british twins in
hospital in mexico after being attacked
by a crocodile
is crowdfunding for their medical fees
the gofundme says the
details of the ordeal are still not
fully known but one of the sisters has
water on her lungs
and the other is in a medically induced
coma
writing on the page their older sister
says this my family
is overwhelmed with the pride that
georgia managed to take the brave action
she did
but now are faced with the difficulty of
traveling to mexico
to support them and pay for their
medical care there is
yet there as yet isn't clarification on
how much we'll need
but already it feels very overwhelming
mel and georgia goes on are in real need
of their parents and those
most amazing medical assistants we can
get to turn this awful
accident away from tragedy
i'm going to be talking about that in
more detail apparently as i said details
very sketchy but it appears that
they were swimming in a lagoon after
dark one of the sisters was taken by a
crocodile the other one who's a diver
went under the surface to
uh help her sister dragging her back to
the boat that they jumped off
crocodile came and attacked them again
cannot even believe it can you stuff of
nightmares
more on that as i said throughout the
course of the morning also
are other main stories for you today and
at least 10 people have been killed and
18
injured in an armed attack on an ngo
base
in afghanistan the attack in the
northern baglan province targeted mine
workers
as part of the u.s and uk ngo trust
halo sky news understands no british or
u.s nationals were involved in the
incident
mps and peers are calling for a ban
of the sale of cigarettes to under-21s
the cross-party report published today
urges the government to use the
opportunity provided by brexit
become a world leader in tobacco control
they're calling it a smoking epidemic
proof of full coronavirus vaccination
will be one way of gaining entry to a
sporting event for the first time on
sunday
for england's opening euro 2020 match
against croatia
another option for supporters will be a
negative lateral flow test taken within
48 hours of the game
wembley will still only be at 25
capacity
22.5 000 people
president of the united states is due to
arrive in the uk later on ahead of the
g7 summit
joe biden arriving in cornwall late
tonight
the first bilateral for the g7 summit is
due to take place between
president biden and the pm on thursday
on friday the uh summit officially
begins with most foreign leaders
attending
arriving in cornwall this will include
leaders
of countries that aren't part of the g7
including
australia the first plenary meeting will
take place
on saturday and the group will have
their family photo taken
as we often see probably with social in
fact definitely with social distancing
talks will continue into sunday with the
summit wrapping up
and later on sunday president joe biden
will meet the queen at windsor castle
some of the biggest websites went down
across the world yesterday thanks to a
glitch at a little-known company that
helps the internet to operate smoothly
amazon netflix and spotify were among
the sites that went offline
along with several leading news outlets
and the official uk government side
cloud computing provider fastly said it
was behind the issue
now jewel leaper has been named the uk's
most played artist
of 2020.
[Music]
her second album future nostalgia was
released four days after the start of
lockdown in march last year
it ends ed sheeran's reign he had held
since the title
uh in 2017.
time for a quick look at what's
happening as far as the weather is
concerned now kirsty was telling us
it's going to be fantastic towards the
end of the week what about today kirstie
good morning
morning kate it actually looks fantastic
for many of us at the moment as well the
downsides of summer weather will be
very high uv levels increasing risk of
grass pollen as well but
yeah yeah i'm hearing him at year we're
all quite glad to see some sunshine
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning the zora's high means we've
got some very fine and settled weather
to come for many
with temperatures increasing as we head
towards the weekend
it is a little bit cloudier in the north
and west though here we've got some
atlantic weather fronts bringing thicker
clouds spots of rain and drizzle maybe
some heavier rain for time
in western scotland so cooler breezier
cloudier the rain at times in the north
and west but temperatures rising
further south and east up to around 26
or
27 in the london area so feeling quite
warm and humid indeed
it could be that very high uv levels to
watch out for today increasing risk of
grass pollen as well
a lot of low cloud mr mark through rc
coast and english channel coast as well
very small chance of a shower for the
midlands northern england this afternoon
dry for many tonight apart from the very
far north and west but quite a lot of
clouds coming in
a bit of a muggy night great start
tomorrow brightness to come
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
do you remember this story from
yesterday text messages between crime
bosses
organizing million dollar shipments of
drugs they've now been revealed by the
us department of justice
the messages were sent on an app set up
by the fbi clever
in conjunction with other global
authorities as part of operation
ironside with more than 800 people
arrested so far
around the world joining us now is
australia reporter gabriela power who
brought this story to us
yesterday goodness me this keeps going
doesn't it
certainly does okay for the past three
years authorities have been monitoring
the messages between
uh criminals and underworld figures as
they plotted drug deals plotted murders
and
they were doing this fun communicating
on this encrypted app that you mentioned
called
a nom now at its peak there were 17 000
users worldwide sixteen hundred here in
australia so
police have moved in we've seen raids in
every capital city in australia there
have been arrests made
in eighteen countries and as you
mentioned eight hundred
criminal figures have now been detained
the fbi
is praising australia's efforts saying
that it wouldn't be able to get the
result that it has
if it wasn't for australia and our
defense minister says that this shows
australia is
punching above its weight that we have
one of the most successful
law enforcement agencies in the world
now there has been
hundreds of people arrested and it is
expected that we'll see more people
charged in the coming weeks okay okay
for now thank you thanks a lot
coming up shortly palm sandy rose to be
one of the most senior asian women in
the police service
we'll hear her story next
climbing security
trade how best to rebuild
shattered economies after the pandemic
and start looking to the future
these are major issues facing a truly
significant meeting of world leaders
as they come together on the cornish
will agreements made here stand firm
or simply fade away like castles in the
sand
the g7 summit on sky news
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm skye's chief
correspondent
will take you to the heart of stories
that shape our world
our job is to tell the truth this is a
forgotten front line
they are dying here
boys we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us
get ready instructing you to stay at
home
i can't believe we did that it's pretty
special isn't it
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
mandatory evacuation you must leave
i'm greg milam sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
as it is almost impossible to predict
where these fires will go next
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend and
twist
metal are you trying to run me over to
fill it no
go away look like it sir
will you respond to those who made
accusations so philip can you go away
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart of america's opioid
crisis
[Music]
i've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget christchurch has been changed
forever by what happened
[Music]
hello my name is nadja frontier
my name is ryan matthews i'm the marine
assistant
at rather a research station which is to
the west of the west antarctic peninsula
so far i've been here for five months
and it is an absolutely wonderful
[Music]
experience
my name is fatima zazile the founder of
ikisa from kuwait where we face many
environmental problems related to waste
pollution the frustration
and lack of information we are
collecting recyclables
from houses schools and businesses in
order to recycle them
in exchange if you recycle to get a tree
hello again everybody this morning we
are talking about whether
andrew lloyd webber will be arrested and
also sausage wars with the eu what on
earth am i talking about well it's
decision time looming for the government
over whether to proceed with the final
stage of lifting england's lockdown
andrew lloyd webber has said he will
open his theaters regardless on the 21st
of june
and is prepared to be arrested if
authorities try to intervene
i discussed that with the housing
secretary a few moments ago
i'm sure that andrew lloyd webber's
comments are made um
in the heat of the moment what what he's
very serious well he i'm sure he feels
this very strongly but look we all have
to
do our best to abide by he'll be
arrested he says come and arrest us
well we all have to abide by the rules
um
yes isn't it um i'm not going to get
into speculation about that but we want
to get those theaters back open
obviously
as quickly as we can to support people
like andrew lloyd webber so that we can
all enjoy brilliant productions in the
west end once again
fabulous tomorrow cohen is here andrew
lloyd webber being
led out of at one of his theaters in
hancock's is not what the government
wants to see
no in this show is a growing backlash
against what
appears to be um many many people's
viewers softening up for a delay
to the lifting of all social distancing
restrictions on the 21st of june we just
heard
robert jen rick there saying we're
taking a cautious approach
nothing is set in stone we mustn't throw
away all the gains
that we've made obviously yesterday we
saw new measures
for six million people in greater
manchester and lancashire
i think there is a feeling among a lot
of tory mps that this is going to be
delayed for a couple of weeks
and we're seeing the hospitality
industry now saying we really cannot
survive this andrew lloyd webber saying
he's going to open his six west end
venues
put on his production of of cinderella
regardless of what
uh the government says if that goes
ahead i think we're going to see some
really difficult
scenes there that really puts them under
pressure doesn't it because you know
everybody knows who andrew lloyd opera
is doing a production of cinderella
but he would be breaking the law and the
police would be within their rights to
go and arrest him that's tricky
the other thing they've got on their
plate is g7 and this brexit
deal or not sausage wars assists
absolutely sausage wars no laughing
matter in northern ireland where already
people are finding that the
meat products that used to be exported
from the uk are not appearing
on supermarket shelves because for a lot
of companies the paperwork is very
difficult
and now the grace period so we made this
uh the brexit deal in december there was
a grace period of six months
and that is ending in the at the end of
june in three weeks time so we're seeing
lord frost who's the brexit minister who
negotiated that deal
meeting the eu commissioner in london
today maris chefkovich to try and iron
out
some of those issues now back back in
december michael gove told us this was
not a concern
but uh robert generic just told us that
he thought
it was because it's it's turning out to
be quite damaging on the ground
this is what he said i don't think
either side
when we signed up to the protocol
envisaged that the eu would
uh interpret it in such a rigid
and unpragmatic way and we're asking
them to show some common sense and
enable something as simple
as some chilled meats like a sausage to
travel
from gb to northern ireland because the
protocol was
always about ensuring the free flow of
goods between
gb and northern ireland
so brexit all over again essentially
it's not wasn't all done
in the brexit deal because there's still
areas of agreement need to be worked out
in this case on food
and animal products if it is not
resolved then we're looking at
a ban on cold meats from the uk going to
northern ireland
and on a more serious note things like
medicines because
northern ireland has effectively stayed
in the eu single market so it has the eu
medicine regulations
and not the uk ones the eu is saying
well if you want
free flow of trade you need to abide by
our rules
and do that dynamically as in every time
they change it we change ours the uk
government think that i think that is a
step too far so
will they be able to find a compromise
today as the brexit minister said
time is running out remember that oven
ready deal
for now thank you returning to covid now
and
i get a view from the regions more than
four
million people across greater manchester
and parts of lancashire have woken up
this morning
to extra support but with stricter
advice and to help slow the spread of
the delta
covid variant of course the government
is encouraging everyone in those areas
to get the vaccine as soon as they can
sadia chowdhury joining us now from the
etihad stadium where a mass
vaccination center has been set up hello
to you good morning how's it being
received there
good morning well this is one of the
larger vaccination sites in manchester
it opened all the way back in january
and it's
expected to be one of the places where
we might see surge vaccination take
place
in the next few weeks and that is of
course because cases are rising here in
parts of manchester trafford uh tame
size salford all these places more than
doubling in covid cases
in stockport the cases have nearly
trebled that's how serious it is i was
looking at the map yesterday
the quick summary is that it is getting
worse and yesterday of course matt
hancock
announced that uh extra uh package of
support that will be given
uh to places like this and these are
things that he says
have worked in bolton and what we saw in
bolton if you remember
uh is that they were dotted or testing
and these are pcr tests which gets sent
off to those genome experts who can
track where that variant is but also
things like bringing in the army and
letting
local authorities have the discretion on
whether or not
secondary school students should carry
on wearing face masks
um joining the police force in the 1980s
talking about palm
sanders she faced racism and sexism at
work despite that challenge
challenge i should say she rose through
the ranks to become the highest ranking
female asian officer in the metropolitan
police
however new research shows despite uh
legislative change which i can never say
legislative change
sexism and racism are still prevalent
in the british workplace today well
we're lucky to have palm
uh with us this morning alongside her is
investigative journalist stuart preble
the
co-author of palmer's book black and
blue hello to you both thank you so much
for joining us on the programme
this morning uh palm if i can ask you
first of all tell me about why you
wanted to write this book
i thought it was important that i share
my experiences
because there are people that i would
still encourage to join now
and i think it's really important that
the um
everyone considers the police service as
a a viable career
the only way you can make change is to
be being part of that organization
and stuart i mean obviously very well
known face to
lots of journalists and and people
watching uh television many of our
viewers this morning will
will know of your work what happened for
you to
take the time to get involved and help
palm why did you want to get involved
well i've known palm for about 10 years
and you know how it is when people are
sort of sitting around
the dinner table or chatting and people
are telling their anecdotes and
everybody would tell their
their stories and then palm would tell
something about uh the
routine life or her early life
uh when she was uh
the child of first generation immigrants
who spoke no
english and was into a forced marriage
and there were so many of these things
that were just kind of completely
jaw-dropping when she would tell them
but she would tell them just in a very
matter-of-fact sort of way and i said to
her a number of times
really you need to write this down and
she would say well
i'm too busy in any way i don't think
i'm all that special
so i said well let me help you with that
because this is an extraordinary story
that really does need to be told what
sort of experiences
can you share with us palm um this
morning that have helped
shaped um your career what sort of
discrimination have you had to face
um i can share one of my very early
experiences which was um going out on
patrol with a
fellow officer and being called the
people head
and then my fellow officer defending me
and at that time i thought that was
great because i was part of the theme
i'd been accepted
but the officer then went on to say only
we are allowed to call her that p
word you're not so members of the police
service were allowed to call it
call me that p word but not members of
the public
and that that was back in um
19 in the 1990s but then if you bring
the clock forward and you move forward
to 2018
i was vetted to the highest standard
through security service so i i went
through that vetting procedure
which was very intensive and very
intrusive
and then to get access to new scotland
yards to a particular floor in new
scotland yard
i then got an email to say can we
comment can you come and discuss
your indian heritage and um the first
question i was asked at that point and
this is 2018
was how often do you go back
at that point i said well go back to
hansworth in birmingham
is that what you're asking me but they
meant go back to the punjab
which is where my parents are from so
even though
you know 30 years have elapsed that
racism that over racism
is still there and although i'm not
saying that the individual who sent me
that email was racist
what i am saying is that the policies
and the practices
are still racist within the metropolitan
police service
um stuart i'm just looking at some
figures a quarter of uk adults have been
a victim of sexism in the workplace more
than
10 have experienced racism at work as
we've heard there from
palm are you surprised uh in 2021 that
we're still having
to have these conversations well
it is it's shocking by any standards and
when you think you go back sort of 25
years till
the murder of stephen lawrence and the
person inquiry
and if you just look uh in the period uh
since then they've probably been
seven or eight major inquiries
independent inquiries
house of common select committee of one
kind or another and they all say
exactly the same thing that there's some
good intentions and there are some
changes of rules and
people are trying to learn some better
practices
but underneath there is a permafrost
which is to just to do with a culture of
organizations
really being run by middle-aged white
men
who uh it want to perpetuate the old boy
network
and if you're uh if you're have a black
or
asian face uh in the match my feeling is
and there are many many examples that we
talked about in the book
if you keep your head down and you don't
mind and you put up
with daily gratuitous racism or sexism
of one kind or another
you can be fine on the day that you make
any complaint of any kind the system
turns against you
in a way that really i think most people
would find
shocking and uh this is what happened to
arm which is one of the things that
makes her
story so extraordinary but it's a it's
an absolute pattern of behavior
that's happened a number of times that
we talk about in detail in the book
yeah black and blue uh is the new book
uh palm uh ann stewart thank you so much
for taking the time to talk to us this
morning good luck
with the the book i'm sure it was
incredibly difficult to to relive so
many of those
um experiences palm but you were in very
good hands with stuart thank you
thank you very much thanks a lot let's
take it back to politics now labour is
urging the prime minister to end what
they call a catalogue of chaos
on education let's talk about it shall
we with the shadow education secretary
kate green who is with us now hello to
you
um tell us about this new initiative
what are you hoping to
achieve as as the opposition
so today we're calling a vote in
parliament asking
mps to back a plan for children to
recover from the pandemic a plan
that we've put together but which is
very similar to what the government's
own advisor kevin collins
uh advised but of course he resigned
last week and discussed when the
government would only commit to
uh spending ten percent of what he had
said is needed
and we are saying that although children
are resilient and excited to be back in
in class and with their friends and
their teachers
clearly there has been an impact on them
parents and teachers have talked to us a
lot
about the impact on their social and
emotional well-being
and that's why we've proposed and kevin
collins talked about
offering um extra curricular activities
after school to help them to play and
learn and develop
and also of course to make up lost
learning they have spent
many months in some cases out of the
classroom
and while we know that teachers have
done an amazing job and parents have
supported homeschooling
it is right the children do get help to
catch up on
the learning that they've lost and
that's why we are also calling
for um a recovery premium a boost to the
pupil premium
particularly so that teachers can give
extra attention
to those children who need more learning
support how much is that going to cost
so our package of proposals
um and we've costed it really carefully
okay and published it so people can have
a look at all the details
and that's up to 14.7 billion pounds
kevin collins himself
uh the government's advisor who resigned
last week
called for 15 billion pounds the
government has announced
that it will spend one and a half
billion pounds 10 of what we and kevin
collins believe
is needed i know it's a lot of money but
the cost of not doing this apart from it
being
deeply unfair to children and young
people who really ought to be
our priority as we're coming out of the
pandemic but we also know
from from think tanks that the cost of
not investing in children and young
people now
will amount to many many more hundreds
of billions of pounds of cost for our
economy
from lost earnings from from poor
productivity and so on
um down the years so so it's a false
economy and the wrong choice really for
richie sunak not to be
making this investment in children and
young people know
i suppose he would say where on earth am
i going to find that sort of money from
and
when we speak to him we'll ask him in
the meantime children being protected
from covid19 they were wearing face
masks until
uh monday they're not anymore uh
expected to
uh is that the right decision because
there has been an increase in cases
yeah and as you know i'm an mp in
greater manchester where we're now
subject to stricter advice and where
we're also asking for more
support i absolutely support mayor andy
burnham's call for
the government to help us with search
vaccination and
and search supplies for testing so that
we can really get this
uh spread of the infection in greater
manchester and in other parts of the
country
under control and i do think and that
face masks
are are an important mitigation um
and one that i would expect school
certainly in greater manchester but
actually probably in many parts of the
country
um now to think perhaps calling for them
not to be born in school is premature
i think if the government's got good
evidence that we don't need them anymore
it needs to
really make that clear to parents and to
school staff
um i would certainly support any head
teacher who
who says that uh they believe that face
masks should still be needed in school
at least while we go through this period
of of trying to manage down the rise in
the infection rate
are you planning a foreign holiday this
year no i'm not okay i haven't got a
foreign holiday booked and i have to say
i really would be very reluctant to go
through an airport and to travel abroad
partly because of course we've got no
idea the government changes the list of
countries on the green
and amber lists at short notice and
clearly nobody wants that kind of
disruption and cost but i just think the
responsible thing to do this year is
is not to go abroad unless you you know
you have a very good reason a very
important need to do so and i certainly
have absolutely no plans to take a
holiday outside the country this year
good to talk to you thanks for joining
why would you want to if you're in god's
own country in the northwest there
thanks very much indeed
thank you thanks a lot thank you
um i want to talk uh about where we are
with um
decision day freedom day as it's being
called
coveted 19 vaccinations etc etc someone
who
is very up on all of this information is
david nabarro
he is the special envoy on kovid 19 for
the world health organization and chair
of global health at imperial college
and he's joining us now hello to you
hello long time no see please i am i
hope you are
too tell me um about what you think
about the 21st of june
being the day that we will potentially
finally
unlock should that happen
well certainly life has to go on and the
last thing any of us want is
to have people needing to
go on restricting their lives but this
virus has not gone away
in some ways it's lurking and just
waiting to
strike again and uh so i want to suggest
to everybody
please be really really careful by all
means
governments should be releasing
restrictions but
it's really up to people everywhere to
organize their lives
to minimum minimize the amount of
contact they have with others
and to i agree with the last speaker
where their face masks and just keep
that protection going
you know it's not a big thing to do to
mask yourself and
and we want to ask people to go on doing
that and go on being careful
because this virus is just very very
dangerous
and it's very present what would a two
or four week delay
what difference would that make what
would it achieve do you think david
well i'm trying k to again
really reiterate that it can't be
just about restrictions the future for
humanity
is going to require that we adapt our
lifestyles
so that we make it hard for this virus
to spread
i mean we know that the virus is
constantly changing which means that
although
vaccination is a marvelous marvelous
asset
it's not going to be enough we are going
to have to continue
to behave as though the virus is an
ever-present threat
so by all means let the restrictions be
released
but at the same time could could i
encourage
everybody everywhere to go on behaving
carefully
because at school at the university
in the pub in the restaurant in the
social club
the virus is still going to be around
and and it can
come back with a huge surge very very
quickly
boris johnson you'll know has committed
to help vaccinate the entire globe by
the end of next year gon brine pretty
disparaging
saying uh his plan is just a wing and a
prayer
nobody's safe until everybody is safe
what do we need to do to make sure
everyone's vaccinated
well first of all okay i am absolutely
delighted that the british prime
minister
has made this uh a
call to action really for the world to
get vaccinate by the end of next year
and he's going to use his leadership of
the g7
group of nations to make this point so i
think like many
i am hoping that this weekend at carvis
bay
world leaders in the g7 will
just say very clearly we are going to
work together to make sure
that the world is vaccinated adequately
by the end of 2022
that would be a gift to generations to
come
and it's the kind of leadership that
really we're expecting and hoping to see
uh in the coming weeks but you heard
what gordon brown said just to reiterate
that point he was saying yeah it's good
to say that but actually
putting it into practice is pretty
challenging and one of the ways to do it
is
a jab in the um in the developed world
and every time that happens there should
be another one in the developing world
of course i mean i think what um mr
brown is saying is
super sensible but there are many people
offering advice
i mean the reality is that it will be a
massive
undertaking to ensure that everybody has
access to vaccine
it'll be a massive undertaking to make
sure that the enough vaccine is
available and the vaccines are
constantly modified
in the light of new variants emerging
but okay
this is doable it it it's not
in in the big scheme of things a massive
expenditure
it just requires everybody saying we're
going to work together on this job
i know i know that sounds easy uh to say
but i actually believe it's going to
happen okay you know i can't let you go
without asking about those grandchildren
oh yes yes well i still haven't seen
otto but i had a great pic of him the
other day he's he's wonderful but most
important is that max
the one we talked about before tom and
ellen's kid he's walking now he's just
had his first birthday
yesterday and i'm super proud oh that's
fantastic maybe you'll indulge us with
some photographs next time we chat it's
good to talk to you
thank you so much look after yourself
thank you thanks a lot
thanks bye bye-bye his face lights up
doesn't mean when he talks about his
grandchildren
um are we going to be happy about the
weather today here's christy
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning i think many of us will be
happy with the weather today and for the
coming days a little bit of sunshine
just cheers everybody up might be a bit
too hot for some
not everyone's happy of course
temperatures rising quite quickly today
in the strong sunshine
more cloud out to the north and the west
that's where we've got some weather
fronts trying to come in
bringing with us some light rain and
drizzle maybe heavier rain for time
in western scotland but across much of
central and eastern england holding on
to the sunshine
so we're looking around say 26 or 27
very high uv
and increasing grass pollen levels to
watch out for possibly the odd shower
for the midlands northern england
mostly dry night tonight but quite a lot
of cloud rolling in from the west
a bit of a muggy one as well and more
sunshine to come
tomorrow the weather
sponsored by qatar airways